foreign
[Music]
just to get started here my name is Kyle
meggs and I'm one of the product
managers for cloud memory store
with me today is Matt geerling another
product manager for Google Cloud memory
store and joining us in a few minutes is
animesh from Palo Alto networks who's a
distinguished engineer
so let's start by uh talking about the
agenda we're going to talk through today
so first we'll start with the memory
store Service as a whole we'll go over
some overviews service that exists today
then we're going to talk about our brand
new redis cluster launch highlighted
that in green because we're super
excited about that we had a launch blog
go out yesterday that you might have
seen
then animesh is going to talk about Palo
Alto Network's use of memory store in
their cortex data Lake application which
is a huge scale security data processing
app we're talking trillions of events
per day at petabyte scale and then we'll
go into closing
you may have seen this slide before if
you've attended other database sessions
but this is a overview of our portfolio
on the left there you see memory store
in Blue this is a managed service for
redis and memcache
um customers love memory store for three
main reasons one is that it is a managed
service so you don't have to be a redis
expert you don't have to be a memcache
expert you don't have to worry about is
my node is my replica in the same Zone
as my primary we handle all of that for
you so it makes a lot of things simpler
the second is that it has predictable
low latency so you can rely on that low
latency building your applications
potentially downsize the compute
required for your database behind memory
store
um and the third is that when you do
that you can actually save money so
we're going to talk to anamesh about how
Palo Alto networks uses memory store to
downsize their Cloud SQL and actually
saves money overall and improves the
speed of their application which is
pretty great
memory store provides microseconds
latency and is already used by over 90
percent of the top 100 Google Cloud
customers
I have a couple example use cases here
on the right uh the most common one
you're probably familiar with is just a
simple cache so putting memory store in
front of your persistent database so
that when you fetch data first you go to
memory store if it's there you're going
to get it with this ultra low latency if
it's not there then you go to the
database it's going to be higher latency
you can then populate memory store so
the next time you need that data you can
fetch it with that ultra low latency so
that's kind of the biggest use case we
also have session store here so imagine
you're a retailer and you're doing an
online checkout we want to keep that
user's session data in memory so we can
access it with super low latency and
give a really nice user experience
third I'll mention leaderboards so you
know obvious for gaming companies you
want to have leaderboards you want to
take advantage of redis sorted sets and
you get these nice data structures to
make this all really easy or maybe your
fintech company and you're showing stock
tickers at the top of the page again
leaderboards just makes this super easy
and because all this is so easy with
redis it has become the most popular
in-memory store so you can see over time
redis has only grown in popularity
because it is fast versatile it offers
High availability
and developers have just come to love it
so we're excited today to talk about
memory store for redis cluster because
we think it's going to take memory store
to the next level
so let's start and talk about the memory
store for redis service that has existed
if you're on the platform today you may
already be familiar with this memory
store for redis that we have today is
fully managed this means no need to
worry about the underlying
infrastructure you just say that you
want to cache and we'll give it to you
memory store for redis is also highly
available you can scale horizontally
with up to five read replicas with these
five read replicas you can support north
of 1 million read requests per second
with a single instance
in addition to this it is vertically
scalable while online so you can resize
your cache to meet your data needs going
larger or smaller as needed in addition
to this
we are offering an integrated database
maintenance experience we will handle
patching for you we do that in a rolling
upgrade fashion we're integrated with
the maintenance window framework that
you might be familiar with that other
gcp services use we are integrated with
Cloud monitoring there is Rich metric
support so that you can monitor the
health of your instance you can also
export that to whatever Monitoring
Solutions you might be using today
we've optimized open source redis and
added improvements such as better
failover as well as added memory
protection for your instance when you're
nearing memory exhaustion
and then finally we are backed by the
same 24x7 Google Cloud support that
you're already used to
so those memory store for redis service
as it has existed let's talk about some
of the recent launches the focal point
of today's conversation is the memory
store for redis cluster launch so this
is a new service that supports the open
source redis cluster protocol you can
horizontally scale now so no longer are
you working with uh you know these
single node memory store deployments
single node redis deployments where you
have to replicate the entire data space
to every node now you're horizontally
scaling and sharding out this key space
so that you can reach a much larger
scale
in addition to that a few other launches
we've had this year cuds these are
committed use discounts you may be
familiar with this from some other gcp
products this is a way to pre-purchase
commitments to the service gives you
additional savings you can do these in a
couple different year increments and the
longer your commitment the more that
you'll save off of the list price we
also launched support this summer for
redis 7. this is going to be the latest
major open source version with this
launch came the added functionality of
redis functions it's kind of a spiritual
successor to redis Lewis grips and we
also made significant performance gains
for TLS so when you're comparing against
TLS on Reddit six or older memory store
instances you're going to see
significantly lower latency and
significantly higher throughput so if
you are using TLS on on memory store we
strongly recommend upgrading the red S7
you're going to get the best possible
experience with no added cost
then the last one axt and DRZ these are
access transparency and data residency
this is going to give you audit logging
of any access events to your instance as
well as some data locality guarantees as
for the
residency of data that you store within
your memory store instance these were
key features to help unlock memory store
and use cases and some of the more
regulated Industries so we've been
seeing more and more customers in this
regulated space who are now able to
adopt the service
so let's talk about memory store for
redis cluster which is now available in
preview
so what is memory store for redis
cluster give you gives you consistent
performance at scale we've got a UI shot
on the left here when you deploy a
memory store for redis cluster you
choose a region A Shard count and the
number of replicas per shard
and when you do this you get an open
source redis cluster managed for you the
fact that we support the open source
rediscluster protocol means a couple
different things one you're not going to
need to perform any type of expensive
application rewrites and to your
migration to the service is going to be
very simple
uh as you do this the benefits of this
horizontally scalable sharded deployment
you can you can deploy up to 250 shards
for a given cluster and this means
multiple terabytes of of key space and
memory footprint associated with an
instance over three terabytes
when you do this you also are able to
scale in and out while the cluster is
online and as you scale in and out you
basically can size to your needs and we
will automatically rebalance the keys
for you so imagine you provision a
cluster of 100 shards for whatever your
data data needs were yesterday over time
you might be expiring Keys you don't
need that full 100 shards anymore you
can shrink that cluster to whatever size
you need now and we will automatically
rebalance keys from the nodes that
you're removing
in addition to this as you scale out
each additional Shard is going to give
you more throughput for your cluster so
you can continue to scale with your
traffic needs
uh and so what does this do this really
takes memory store to new heights in our
minds so over the past few years we've
heard your concerns about the memory
store for redis service which maybe
meets the scale requirements that you
have today but it doesn't meet the scale
requirements that you might have
Tomorrow based on how you expect your
application or workload to grow over
time and so with the new service memory
store for redis cluster we're seeing a
60 times Improvement in total throughput
that can be supported by an instance and
a 10 times Improvement of amount of data
that is supported by a single instance
as well and so we see tons of Headroom
to scale here again you can also scale
in and out as needed so you can pay as
you go and you can pay for the size of
the cluster that you need as you scale
in and out you're going to get
consistent and predictable Performance
Based On The Shard count associated with
your instance and what we're hearing
from customers is that they're starting
to consider taking their many smaller
memory store for instances that exist
today on the Standalone service taking
and consolidating these instances into
one large cluster and they're going to
be able to realize huge cost savings
from doing this while also giving
themselves all this additional Headroom
to scale in the future
and one of the things I alluded to
earlier was the high availability so
with memory store for redis cluster this
is super easy when you provision a
cluster we make sure to put the
primaries in different zones when you
add replicas which is a single click of
a button we make sure the replicas are
in a different Zone than the primary so
you can get four nines SLA extremely
easily and with all that as well if
there's a VM failure or even if there's
a zonal failure the failover is
automatic and fast to the replica so
rather than having to do this yourself
on GCE memory store for redis cluster
just makes this super super easy
I'll also mention we're integrated with
the best of Google Cloud so we're
launching with support for private
service connect or PSC which means that
you can have your client and your VPC
and you can connect to memory store in
the Google VPC and your traffic never
leaves the cloud it's easy to provision
these clusters one-click automation
again and we also addressed one of the
previous issues with IP address
allocation so even if you have 250
shards you only need two IP addresses
for your cluster so a lot of quality of
life improvements here with PSC
and then of course we're integrated I
think Matt mentioned some of these were
integrated with security and monitoring
so you get I am out of the box you can
centrally manage you have redis auth uh
TLS audit logging which you mentioned
and last of course Cloud monitoring so
it's easy to set up monitoring on your
cluster you monitor is the cluster too
big is cluster running too hot maybe I
need to add shards maybe I need to
remove shards and again that's really
all about making sure you're spending
the right amount of money
and now this is the end of our
presentation we're going to bring on
animesh chaturvedi from Palo Alto
networks where he's a distinguished
engineer
[Applause]
hi everyone my name is Anime chaturvedi
I'm representing Palo Alto networks here
so Palo Alto networks is a global cyber
security leader we deliver Innovations
which enable secure digital
Transformations our mission is to be
cyber security partner of choice and we
deliver basically these Transformations
with our best of breed platforms
world-class threat Intel and expert
Services which bring to the table what's
next in cyber security and cortex data
lake is one such platform which is the
focus of our presentation today and I'm
gonna talk about it so animesh prior to
this preview launch that we're talking
about today we had a smaller private
preview for a few select customers like
yourself to try out the product early
you had a chance during that period how
did that go well it was awesome and I
was very impressed with the results I
was looking for basically three key
things first is simplicity so it was
very easy to deploy a new cluster add
and remove shards as needed performance
and scalability as we add as I added
more Shard the performance basically
grew proportionately and in terms of as
a managed service basically we do not
have to worry about the deployment side
and operations of it we don't need to
have radius expertise uh in-house and
then it also integrates very well with
various Google ecosystem like IAM which
makes it easy to adopt okay so it sounds
like testing during private preview went
well now that we're announcing public
preview and expanding like this do you
plan to adopt redis cluster yes
certainly so we have a number of micro
Services which constitute this cortex
data Lake many of them use their own
private deployment of memory store some
of them are sort of over provisioned and
we have some challenges with consistency
in terms of uh in terms of like security
as well as in terms of like the
compliance and other aspects of it by
consolidating all of these smaller
clusters smaller deployments into manage
cluster I expect to save cost as well as
get much better SLA I think with our
redis manage cluster we get four lines
of slas so we are really looking forward
to it
yes awesome so now let's dive deeper
into how animesh is using memory store
today in his production use case of
Cortex data lake or CDL all right so
this is basically a classical
memory store use case as a caching for
our application cortex data lake is a
very large scale data platform which
basically processes data that comes from
various parallel to firewalls and
security applications to dig a little
bit deeper basically firewalls are
processing traffic in a given Enterprise
coming in and out and as they process
this traffic they apply security
policies
the application of the security policy
on the traffic generate huge amount of
data the second service that Palo Alto
has is network connectivity as a service
this is basically known as Prisma access
and the platform is called secure access
service edge this is where we connect
users to Applications these applications
can be in like a third-party SAS
provider or on-prem and we also connect
users to internet via this secure
Gateway so now this basically also
generates huge amount of data and then
there are many other Palo Alto
applications which also produce events
to this data platform so the amount of
data that we receive is insane you can
imagine there are thousands of customers
with many thousands of firewall
deployments they are generating huge
amount of data and as such we need a
data platform a robust data platform
which can ingest and process up to
trillion events per day
so it does sound like a great use case
for redis but I'm sure a lot of the
audience knows as well that there's many
different options for redis on Google
Cloud what led you to choose memory
store so of course there are many
options available you can roll up your
sleeves deploy a redis on GCE or gke or
use a third party one of the third party
providers of redis on Google Cloud but
we went with gcp first of all we have a
great partnership with Google and uh
being a managed service we do not have
to worry about uh like when you deploy
anything in the cloud you have to expect
that the underlying node on which your
workload is running at some point will
get recycled out or patched and so so
that's something as a managed service is
abstracted from us the Simplicity and
the performance and scale all that we
get from a memory store basically we can
focus on our business and rely on Google
for the operations of this critical
service for us
nice now let's Deep dive into the CDL
architecture itself
all right so CDL as I mentioned is a
very large scale security data platform
we leverage a number of Google cloud
services uh it's a micro service based
environment so we use Google uh gke
quite a bit GK gives us a lot of Auto
scaling and resiliency uh we use anthos
service mesh this is the service mesh
that basically helps us manage various
micro Services we also use enthus
service mesh as an API Gateway and we
use various Google data stores like
bigquery Cloud SQL bigtable Etc and of
course memory store to speed things up
when we query these various data stores
all right so in terms of memory store we
have a number of different deployments
for various micro Services I'll group
them into four categories first is
ingestion service then we have the
control plane and then the third one is
our data processing service and fourth
is the query service
next
so from an uh from an ingestion
perspective from a onboarding workflow a
customer basically goes to Palo Alto
networks portal they create a virtual
data Lake for themselves in a particular
region then they associate their
parallel to applications or firewalls
with the particular data virtual data
Lake that they have provisioned at this
point firewalls connect to a service
asking for where should we send data we
give them a unique fqdn for that virtual
data Lake the firewall connects to this
ingestion service injection services are
very large scale service running in gke
and gke gives us Auto scale and
resiliency or daytime to night type
traffic is typically uh daytime is
almost twice as night time so Auto
scaling is very important for us to
basically scale down and save cost as
well as we get few spikes so we want to
make sure we are able to address those
spikes so gke basically gives us all of
that and uh and and with this basically
because we are running this data
pipeline for many thousands of customers
this is very large scale and we have to
process up to trillion events per day
so you have this gke service that's Auto
scaling for the event load that you have
coming in you're enriching that data
with the cache data that's in memory
store trillion events per day how do you
manage that scale past that point so
very a very very good question so in
order to manage such a large data
service you need a very robust control
plane the robust control plane basically
needs to
extract various data pipeline components
the firewall metadata the connectivity
for various firewalls making sure that
they are all able to send data and we
and the customer metadata we are able to
enrich the logs with contextual data
from from customers environment all of
this metadata is kept in Cloud SQL and
we put memory store in front to speed up
the pipeline thereby reducing our
compute as well as making our pipeline
lot more efficient right so the logical
next question might be what if you
didn't have memory store to speed things
up what if you had to rely only on the
database base behind all right so if
memory store was not there then our
pipeline would have to basically make
metadata query calls to the underlying
SQL store which typically is much higher
latency now with that higher latency the
throughput of per parallelization is
would be much smaller but we still need
to maintain that trillion events per day
kind of speed so in order to do that we
would have to increase our
parallelization that means we have to
bring in lot more compute and and that
means the cost of the pipeline would be
much higher right so by using memory
store you can both speed up the
application and actually save money
because you need fewer resources
elsewhere
that's correct and the third service is
the data processing service we use Kafka
as our messaging layer we have put lots
of innovation and tooling around Kafka
to work at our scale we are able to on a
spike we are able to increase partitions
we are able to add our retired topic so
when we have to let's say reduce
partition we'll transition to a new
topic and then clean out the old topic
we are able to seamlessly add new
clusters as our demand grows and uh and
all of this information is kept in in
basically the metadata service or the
control plane the control plane knows uh
where for a given customer which Kafka
topic and cluster the data resides in
the control plane also knows which data
store the the data should be transferred
over to so to the right of the Kafka
Kafka cluster is our various workloads
the workload up top is our persistent
job this reads reads data data from
Kafka it talks to the control plane via
the memory store to look up which Kafka
topic or cluster to read data from and
then looks of the control plane again to
figure out what uh what their tenant
project and which data set should we be
writing the data to at the bottom are
various Palo Alto streaming applications
these are real-time applications reading
data from Kafka applying filtering and
enrichment and then sending the Matched
data streams to the application
endpoints
and the fourth in the final service is
the query service query service provides
the abstraction for underlying data
store
when a query from a UI or API comes in
it looks up the control plane with the
memory store in front of it as to figure
out where the data for that particular
query resides in our in our data
warehouse it runs those query jobs
executes the query jobs caches the
results and presents it to the UI or API
as needed now in this case also you can
see we are using memory store so net net
we are we have memory store sprinkled
across all of our services and this
helps us make our pipeline much more
efficient and scalable and cost
effective
great well thanks everybody we're
closing now so that's that's all we had
for today just to recap we're super
excited about the memory store for redis
cluster launch so please give that a try
that's now in public preview
um and we have our emails up here so if
you have questions or feedback please
feel free to reach out to us directly
foreign